he's nominated for a Best directing
Oscar tonight welcome Martin Scorsese
Jean Hersholt was an actor from Denmark
who made his own mark in Hollywood
playing saintly doctors on screen and
who's off-screen character was equally
admirable his concern and care and for
the comfort of all workers who helped
make movies inspired our Academy to
establish a minute Aryan Award in his
name
now the Hirsch hold Awards not given
every year but this year it's been voted
to veteran film executive Roger Mayer
whose humanitarian efforts add luster to
the golden statuette named Oscar like
Herr Schultz himself Raj is one of the
good guys
Roger Mayer's long involvement with and
brilliant leadership of the motion
picture and television fund is without
precedent this compassionate group acts
as a safety net providing charitable
social and medical assistance to those
in our industry the MPT f takes care of
its own
like no other in the arena of film
preservation a cause close to my own
heart as founding chair of the National
Film Preservation Foundation the
collector and protector of cinematic
treasures he has ensured that our past
lives on for future movie goers with his
crucial work in saving both films and
those that make films he has earned this
award twice over
for all of the love he has shown for all
of us we gratefully presented this Jean
Hersholt Award to my friend Roger Mayer
thank you so much Marty thank you your
kind introduction to John bloom for that
wonderful film by the way as many of you
know Marty's film foundation has been a
leader in the film preservation movement
just as Jean Hersholt was a leader in
the motion picture and television fund
and interestingly enough he contributed
the land on which our hospital
retirement community and Alzheimer's
unit were built so there's a real
connection there as for film
preservation I must give credit to the
six Board Chairman 7 production heads
during my 25 years at MGM who either
backed our endeavors or weren't quite
sure what we were doing so let it happen
anyway and then came Ted Turner and his
cohorts in Atlanta who understood the
importance of all this and kept it going
even when funds were pretty short
preservation and restoration are now led
by the studios and organizations
nationwide such as the Museum of Modern
Art in Eastman house in New York
UCLA and our own Academy Archives here
in Los Angeles and most particularly the
Library of Congress and as I thank the
Academy's Board of Governors for this
great honor I want to remind all of you
that the Academy itself namely you
support film preservation and healthcare
through both the motion picture and
television fund and the National Film
Preservation Foundation so we sincerely
thank you and of course most importantly
thanks to my family all of whom are here
tonight my children Patty and Larry
daughter-in-law Jennifer sister Florence
granddaughters Natasha Nana and most
especially my wife of 52 and a half
years spalling
fifty two and a half years and they say
nothing less in Hollywood well love
really does taking care of our own does
and the art of film does if we properly
preserve it so I'm gonna keep at it and
hope you will continue your support
thank you very very much